[Music]
foreign
all right so we are talking about how to
use the Laplace transform to make pves
simpler to solve pdes
specifically by LaPlace transforming out
one of the the independent variables
so that this partial differential
equation becomes an ordinary
differential equation
uh one of these I have done this on the
heat equation this lecture I'm going to
do it on the wave equation and just to
remind you you can definitely solve
these kinds of heat equations and wave
equations uh on infinite domains uh
where with nice boundary conditions
where things Decay to zero using the
Fourier transform but if you have a
one-sided semi-infinite domain we need
to do it with the Laplace transform
and we'll need boundary conditions and
initial conditions so for the wave
equation u t t the second partial
derivative of U with respect to time
equals c squared u x x the second
partial of U with respect to space uh
here let me just write down that U of x
and t is basically going to be the
height of some rope so every kid when
you were younger right you like flipped
a rope and you know that sent traveling
waves down that rope so we're basically
going to be shaking a rope at the Left
End and sending traveling waves down
that rope so this is uh position x
equals zero it goes to X you know tends
to Infinity the Rope is being shaken at
one end which generates traveling waves
generates
traveling
traveling waves
and U of x and t is going to be kind of
the height or the displacement of this
rope at a location X at a time t
so this is essentially kind of the
height
um
height rope
at X comma T at space at point x at time
t
good and so now I need some initial
conditions and some boundary conditions
and so the first thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to say that I'm going to be
shaking the Rope up and down and I'm
going to say that that's I'm going to
try to keep my boundary conditions blue
so I want to say that this up and down
motion is f of T some forcing in time so
I'm going to say that you at location x
equals 0 for all of time is equal to
sorry it's so squeaky
F of T this is my boundary condition oh
that's real squeaky
and then my initial condition is going
to be that at time 0 I'm going to have U
of X at time 0 equals zero and I'm also
going to have that the derivative that
it's not just at position zero passing
through with some velocity but then it
really has zero velocity that u x
sorry sorry u t u sub t
at X at time 0 also equals zero so the
position is zero everywhere at Time Zero
and the velocity
is zero at all locations X at Time Zero
these are going to be my
initial conditions
and we're going to look
we'll perform this PD
s and boundary conditions to get a
solution okay and again you always have
to think to yourself do I Laplace
transform in space or in time because
the whole point here is that we are
removing one of these independent
variables we're turning it into a
LaPlace variable which is essentially
going to be like a constant compared to
the other variable and so you have to
decide am I LaPlace transforming in time
or in space and remember when you
Laplace transform something
that has a second derivative you're
basically going to get
um
you know s squared times that that
function plus s times the first
derivative of the function plus the
second derivative of the function
evaluated either at zero yeah at zero
and so whichever if I have two boundary
conditions or if I have two initial
conditions I'm going to use the one that
I have two of and Laplace transform in
that variable since I have two initial
conditions in time and two time
derivatives if I Laplace transform in
time I'll have enough information to
satisfy that Laplace transform so you
should actually try this try to Laplace
transform in space and you'll run up
against a wall pretty quickly because
you won't have enough boundary
conditions so it's like a good exercise
I asked my students to do
so we're going to
um maybe I'll I'll uh yeah I'll do this
right here
so we're going to uh Laplace transform
in
time
so my markers are all squeaky because
I've been here all day filming so I
hiked up from my home to the university
with a guitar on my back to do the wave
equation lecture now I'm doing Laplace
transforms it is the evening it is a
holiday and my pens and I are both
feeling very squeaky and dry
uh but you know I know that many of you
are learning this material in nights and
weekends you have a full-time job maybe
you have a family uh and you're learning
this in your spare time and that's why I
am teaching you in my spare time because
it matters and because you're putting in
the time
so we're going to Laplace transform in
time
and we're going to use our two initial
conditions hopefully uh
to satisfy that initial data in this
Laplace transform
and that's because I have two time
derivatives and two initial conditions
so Laplace transform in time is uh
actually quite simple It's s
squared
U Bar of X comma s
so remember U is a function of space and
time but I'm laplossing in time so now U
Bar is a function of X and my LaPlace
variable s
my second derivative in time became an S
squared times U Bar
uh and then remember when you Laplace
transform something that has a second
derivative you also have a minus s
times the first time derivative of x at
time zero this is kind of my first
initial condition at Time Zero
minus uh U of X comma zero equals c
squared
U Bar x x and remember
if I Laplace transform u x x with
respect to time
that's the same as taking the second
partial derivative of U Bar my LaPlace
of U with respect to time you should
just work that out on a little napkin or
piece of paper it's really simple if you
have a function of space and time I can
Laplace transform it in time and then
take two partial derivatives or I can
take two partial derivatives in X and
then Laplace transform in time and
they're equal to each other so this is
just U Bar sub x x
now the nice thing is is that my initial
conditions for this and for this are
both zero I did that on purpose
obviously
but it's a physical scenario my rope
started out you know I laid it flat on
the ground at zero and I'm going to
start whipping it that's a very physical
initial condition is that these are both
zero so these are zero by my initial
conditions
so that's super cool right out of the
gate we LaPlace transformed this thing
our initial conditions allowed us to
kill these two kind of pesky terms that
always crop up when you Laplace
transform something with multiple
derivatives these kind of initial
condition terms
and now I just have my equation s
squared U Bar
equals c squared U Bar x x
and this is an ordinary differential
equation in X this is a second order
linear ordinary differential equation in
X we know how to solve ordinary
differential equations because we got
rid of you know here we had two partials
partial and x and partial and Y and T
here this only has partials in X so it's
an ordinary differential equation so
this is I'll just write that this is an
ode
in in x
and so we know how to solve this ode in
X using kind of you know simpler math
pdes are generally thought of as more
complicated than Odes it's more involved
to solve them so this should be easier
to solve than this
so let's let's solve this uh expression
here I think what I would probably do
is you know divide both sides by c
squared so I have U prime prime I'm just
going to write it out so I'm going to
have like U
bar x x
minus
s squared over c squared U Bar equals
zero and so this thing is going to have
eigenvalues plus or minus root S over C
and so those are going to be the two
basic Solutions
are going to be I'm just going to write
it out here so the two basic Solutions
are going to be
um
yeah the two basic Solutions are going
to be U Bar of X comma s
equals
an e to the
Plus
or an e to the minus s over c x and an e
to the plus s over c x and these each
have coefficients out front there's
going to be you know some a and some B
coefficients and just like when we did
this for the heat equation I hope you've
seen that one these coefficients are
constants with respect to X
but that means that they can be
functions of s they can be whole
transfer functions a bar of S and B Bar
of s and we're actually going to
determine these constants the these
transfer functions using the boundary
condition here that we haven't used yet
so we already used our initial
conditions we're going to determine
these using our boundary conditions
um
good let's see
all right um and we know that when we
flick this rope it's never going to blow
up to Infinity like no one's that
powerful maybe Thor if he you know
flicks a rope he can make it blow up at
Infinity but we can't and so this thing
has to Decay to zero as X goes to
Infinity so that right out of the gate
kills this positive term here so this
term basically B has to equal zero
uh for a bounded
solution
and I'm kicking myself because this
should have been a blue X and a blue
writing because this is kind of a
boundary condition that it has to remain
bounded this should be blue b equals
zero okay unless you're Thor and so now
this is the only term in the solution
super simple right like we LaPlace
transformed we used our initial
conditions this is the only term that
can be in the solution uh and to some
extent this is really easy because now
we're going to use this left boundary
condition
where we set x equal to zero e to the
zero is one
and so a bar s is equal
a bar s
is equal to U Bar
of x equals zero
comma s
and U Bar of zero comma s is just the
Laplace transform of my forcing
F of T this U Bar is just the Laplace
transform of U
at spatial location x equals zero at
time T and that's you know F of t so
essentially u-bar at x equals zero comma
s is just the Laplace transform of my
boundary condition so this entire a bar
s is just my Laplace transform of my
boundary condition very very simple this
is actually like an easier example of
Laplace transforms for pdes than the
heat equation maybe I should have
started with this one but I'm ending
with this one
and so so the solution I'll just write
it here so the solution
the full solution in LaPlace domain is U
Bar X comma s equals
you know
um I'll call this
F Bar
F Bar of s is just the Laplace transform
of my forcing F of T times
e to the minus s over C
X
that's it that's my solution this is my
entire solution to this rope being
shaken one way kind of semi-infinite
domain wave equation
now I'll have to inverse Laplace
transform this to get something that has
a Time variable instead of a LaPlace
variable that's a little bit tricky so
this is
um
in frequency in time I'm going to get U
Bar of X comma T equals
and you're going to have to take my word
for it that when you inverse Laplace
transform this construction here some
function of s times e to the minus s
over c x
essentially what this does is it kind of
time shifts this function so what this
is is this is f
of
t
minus X over C you could either compute
this using the inverse Laplace transform
formula you could look in the back of a
textbook for you know the the lookup
table you could do this in you know
Wolfram Alpha or Mathematica you could
derive this from scratch but this is the
answer is that this this expression here
essentially shifts the solution F of T
by you know X over C that's how much it
shifts it by
and there's a detail here
this function is only defined I should
have probably written this down here
this is only defined for T greater than
or equal to zero and X greater than or
equal to zero
and so I have to multiply this by a
heavy side function and my heavy side
function is T minus X over C this is
kind of a technical mathematical detail
the heavy side function uh literally
I'll draw you a picture of it but it's
something that only turns on when this
is positive okay because that's really
important this argument has to be
positive
um for this for this solution
so this is actually the honest to
goodness solution this is the solution
uh
in time
this is the solution in
frequency domain
side means and I'm going to draw you a
picture of oh this is not a u-bar sorry
you should be screaming into your uh
your screens right now this is you not
Laplace transform this is in the
original coordinates x and t
is this thing so I'm going to show you
what this heavy side function is and
then I'm going to draw you a big picture
of kind of how information propagates in
a space-time diagram for this problem
okay so the heavy side function
is pretty simple to visualize
um essentially I'm going to look at this
heavy side function and I'm going to
first fix X and very T and then I'm
going to fix T and Vary X and we're
going to see what happens the heavy side
function is a function
that is 0
when the argument is
less than zero when the thing inside is
less than zero it's zero and it becomes
one when the argument inside becomes
positive
so it's like this and it kind of jumps
discontinuously at that location
[Music]
so we're going to fix
a
and very
t so this is in the T Direction
and so this argument for a fixed X this
argument becomes positive and this heavy
side jumps to being positive when T
equals
X over C
so at some location
basically there will be some time X over
C after which information will hit that
location X so there is a time before
which information doesn't reach a
certain location in X that's kind of
what this heavy side is saying is that
it takes time for information to
propagate I'll draw you another picture
in a minute the other way to understand
this heavy side function is to fix
uh
uh t
and very X it's a little bit more
complicated not really if I fix T in
very X this thing becomes positive when
x equals c times t
so similarly when x equals c times T
this thing will jump up and information
will start propagating at that location
X
so at a fixed time at a fixed time there
will only be certain X's where
information will have propagated
oh I really botched this is a
the inverse of this because
sorry because this is a minus sign here
it's X less than CT where this is
positive for X less than CT this is
positive
and for X greater than CT this is
actually the argument is less than zero
and so my heavy set is actually like
this
when I fix time and very X convince
yourself of that remember our heavy side
function when this argument is less than
zero the heavy side is zero and when
this argument is greater than zero heavy
side is one
and so if I fix T then for x
less than CT this thing is positive and
I have one and when it's greater than CT
this argument is negative and I have my
heavy set zero it's a little messy
but at the end of the day what we're
trying to do is solve this this PD the
wave equation this is the solution
that's what you get when you when you
Laplace transform you use your initial
conditions you use your boundary
conditions you get that it's only this
term in LaPlace domain this term right
here where F Bar is the Laplace
transform of my forcing my boundary
condition
and when you inverse Laplace transform
you get this weird relationship that you
get this shifted version of my my
forcing times the heavy side and my
heavy side behaves this way
so now I'm going to draw you a picture
physically of what's happening and this
is going to make I think uh way way way
more sense okay
so our forcing
uh and I'll draw it in blue are forcing
F of T
literally in time is going to be some
forcing remember you're a kid you're
just whipping this uh jump rope you know
it's draped out in front of you and
you're just whipping this thing at some
you know F and you're trying to make it
as crazy as possible that's the F that
you're sending propagating through this
this rope
okay so that that's F of T and so now
what we're going to do is we're going to
draw something called an x t diagram
and this is used all the time in physics
especially in things like shock wave
physics or you know the propagation uh
soliton physics and Optics and lasers if
you look at shock waves in fluids like
over a missile or a bullet you're going
to be drawing XT diagrams
X
T and so now this forcing in time
it's at location x equals zero so it's
at x equals zero x equals zero in time
this is my forcing function so I'm
forcing this thing at x equals zero at
time T this is my boundary condition
forcing
and essentially what happens is along
this characteristic line x equals CT
if x equals c times T this thing is
equal to zero and this is equal to zero
essentially what you find is that
information propagates in this x t
diagram at a certain speed
so all of these kind of
all of this information propagates
linearly like this
so what happens is if I go to a
downstream location X let's say I go to
this location you know X whatever
then at a certain time in the future
my initial forcing that I've already
done is appearing at that Downstream
location X so that forcing Position will
essentially be traveling down that rope
this is it traveling down that rope to
farther and farther locations Downstream
to farther and farther X's as time
progresses as that information has time
to travel down to those Downstream
locations
so this is the line this line here is
super important and this basic line here
should be in a different color probably
this this line here that's kind of pink
and yellow this is the line x equals CT
along which information propagates so
this is kind of a characteristic we call
this the wave front
or the characteristic line of this
problem and below this here
U equals zero because no information and
so at a really really really really far
Downstream location X you know 10 20
meters Downstream
for short times no information is
propagated there so it's still equal to
zero until enough time has passed that
this initial wave front can reach that
location so this is the wave front this
is literally that like first part of the
motion when I just started turning this
thing on at Time Zero that is now
traveling at this speed and that forcing
pattern is traveling Downstream on on my
rope
really really important in capturing
physics traveling wave physics for the
wave equation pretty much the wave
equation has what's known as traveling
wave physics that's where the word wave
comes from are these you know these
waves that are kind of coherent and
traveling uh in time with these XT
diagrams okay so that's the kind of
intuition you can build when you solve
these things using the Laplace transform
and you can do it on weird domains so we
are usually used to thinking of infinite
domains where X goes you know negative
infinity and positive Infinity in which
case if I forced my rope you know in the
middle of an infinite rope those waves
would travel both left and right I would
get waves going in both directions the
two-way wave equation until either you
know it dies out at an infinity or until
it hits some kind of boundary condition
that's so far away that maybe it starts
reflecting back like maybe it's in the
middle of a gigantic guitar string or
something like that
um so those are the kinds of things you
can play around with uh changing the
boundary conditions changing the size of
the domain and thinking about how these
Solutions change but this idea of an XT
diagram
this is why we need the heavy side
function literally so that you know
there are certain times at which
information will hit
that X location and there are certain X
locations where the information is zero
until a certain time is is is reached
okay uh this is an example of how you
solve pdes with Laplace transforms to
turn them into Odes and then to use
initial conditions and boundary
conditions all right thank you